Ось так курчата, які щойно вилупилися,
падають із конвеєра.
Ніби якийсь неживий промисловий продукт.
Так вони проводять перший день свого життя.
А всього їм ще залишилося жити лише 41 день.
Доля пташенят визначена наперед: коли підростуть,
усі вони опиняться на тарілці.
Своє коротке життя вони проведуть тут,
на промисловій птахофермі у селі
Кондраєць-Панський у центральній Польщі.
У приміщенні, що нагадує ангар, утримують 54 тисячі курчат.
Птахи за своє життя не бачать ані неба, ані трави.
Утім, їхні господарі запевняють, що добре про них піклуються
- Ветеринар приходить до нас щодня.
Іноді навіть двоє. Вони ходять по пташні
і спостерігають за поведінкою і фізичним станом курчат.
У більшості випадків, якщо й виникають проблеми,
то це пов'язано з розладом травлення.
Але жодного ризику для споживачів немає.
Чи справді благополуччя покупців тут на першому місці?
Польська курятина не раз опинялася в центрі харчових скандалів,
зокрема через виявлену сальмонелу в тушках польських бройлерів,
у тому числі й в Україні. Зворотний бік медалі -
аби кури не хворіли, їх загодовують антибіотиками.
У програші також споживачі, які
разом із курячим м'ясом на тарілці отримують
ще й порцію антибіотиків.
- Що викликає велике занепокоєння у споживачів,
то це сучасне використання антибіотиків на фермах.
Є урядовий звіт, який засвідчує, що інспекції
в курниках - це вигадані випадки.
Зоозахисники - такі, як Анна, -
вважають неприйнятними умови утримання курчат
на великих промислових птахофермах.
Її екологічна організація "Відкриті клітки" розпочала
кампанію під назвою "Франкенкурчак"
за аналогією з монстром Франкенштейном,
щоб засудити практику відгодівлі курчат
до екстремальних розмірів.
Зоозахисники стверджують, що грудна клітка курчат
непропорційно велика порівняно з лапами.
Іноді кістки ніг навіть ламаються, не витримуючи ваги.
- Уявіть собі п'ятирічну дитину вагою 150 кг.
Це неприродно. Ці курчата не ростуть здоровими.
Вони хворі.
Утім, те, що для зоозахисників неприйнятне,
для птахівників - привід для гордощів.
Анджей Гонтарський хвалиться, що в перший день життя
курчата важать лише 40 грамів,
а після 6 тижнів вигодовування на його фермі
мають вагу вже майже три кілограми.
Власне, через 6 тижнів курчат відправляють
на забійний завод. У сусідньому селі Уяздовек
на птахобійні працюють 1600 осіб, і щодня тут
на конвеєрі переробляється 750 000 бройлерів.
Спершу їх знеболюють,
тоді паралізують електричним струмом.
Інша машина розфасовує продукцію
для заморозки або продажу у свіжому вигляді.
Після цього курчата стають продуктом,
який опиняється на полицях магазинів.
- Наша курятина вже давно постачається
не лише в Європу. Вона іде також на африканський
та азійський ринки, що перетворює Польщу
на одного зі світових лідерів.
За останнє десятиріччя Польща стала
провідним виробником і експортером курятини в Європі.
Щорічно тут народжується майже 2 мільярди курчат.
Багато з них експортуються майже відразу,
головним чином у Білорусь та Україну.
Та більше половини відгодовуються в Польщі
для внутрішнього споживання або подальшого експорту.
Головні ринки збуту польських курчат - країни ЄС:
Німеччина, Нідерланди і Великобританія.
Головними ринками з-за меж ЄС є Україна,
Південна Африка й Гонконг,
яких приваблюють насамперед низькі польські ціни.
Торік Польща експортувала близько мільярда курчат
і продовжує нарощувати обсяги виробництва.
За останнє десятиліття обороти галузі зросли вдесятеро.